قمنا بالرحلة في وقت سابق اليوم
وكان من المثير للاهتمام أن نرى على طول
الطرق
وصولًا واضحًا جدًا ولكننا مررنا
بقافلة عسكرية أوكرانية
يبدو أنها استُهدفت عن طريق الجو ، يمكنك
مشاهدة الفيديو الآن لا
يزال هناك دخان يتصاعد هناك
رجال إطفاء  في مكان الحادث أثناء محاولته
إخماد الحرائق ، أعتقد أن إحدى الشاحنات
كانت على الأرجح شاحنة وقود ، لكن تلك التي
أمامها كانت
قاذفة صواريخ متعددة وما هو
مثير للاهتمام في هذا الأمر هو إظهار
أن الروس أصبحوا الآن نوعًا من
الأهداف الصاروخية  بشكل انتهازي
كما ومتى يمكنهم ،
رأينا جنديًا أوكرانيًا واحدًا على الأقل
قُتل بوضوح
في ذلك الهجوم ،
ويظهر لك حقًا مدى صعوبة ذلك
بالنسبة للأوكرانيين الذين ليس لديهم دفاع جوي
لتحريك
الأسلحة بشكل فعال
دون أن يكون  تم استهدافهم ومن الواضح
أن قدرتهم على القيام بذلك
تتضاءل بشكل كبير ، كما
رأينا عندما اقتربنا من المدينة مجموعة كبيرة
من متطوعي الدفاع المدني  العشرات
منهم يقفون هناك على الطريق السريع مع
كومة ضخمة من الإطارات ولا يسع المرء إلا
أن يفترض أن النية هي عندما
تبدأ القوات الروسية بالتحرك على طول هذا
الطريق باتجاه العاصمة
فإنها ستحاول سد ذلك أه
بإشعال النار.  لتلك الإطارات ولكن من
الواضح أن
حرق الإطارات ومتطوعي الدفاع المدني
لا يتناسبان حقًا
مع تطور الجيش الروسي ،
فنحن نعلم أنهم موجودون بالفعل في
قاعدة جوية على مشارف
كييف التي
ذهب إليها زميلي ماثيو فرصة وزارها أمس
كانت القوات الروسية موجودة بالفعل وهناك
شعور بأنه على الرغم من أنهم يواجهون
قدرًا كبيرًا من المقاومة من
الجيش الأوكراني ، إلا أنهم
يضغطون عليها من اتجاهات متعددة ،
ضع في اعتبارك أنه من نافلة القول أن
هذه مدينة يبلغ عدد سكانها ما يقرب من ثلاثة ملايين نسمة.
من الواضح أنه أمر مرعب
للغاية للناس هنا وهم ينتظرون ليروا ما
ستجلبه الليلة